et bien voici attendez attendez je sais
pas ce qu'on nous amène là mais on
dirait les tables de la loi travail pt
franchement je vais vous dire une chose
le syndicat les cyclistes de bouloc
qu'est ce que c'est alors c'est un vélo
un guidon haut
voilà
c'est parfait eh ben c'est pas
envisageable fait voir je la lis parce
que j'ai pas vu à vous me rendrez la
bouteille vous êtes gros on a de quoi
étonner alors qu'ils avaient quasiment 4
j'écris moi mon père abattant sa vie
rangée les manifestations mais pas de
poker les patrons card dakar et repos
repos maintenant s je pose une question
y at il des personnes qui est encore une
banderole y at il des personnes qui est
encore à manifester soit à gauche ou à
droite parce que moi je suis je n'ai y
at il quelqu'un qui a envie de crier
viva tel ou un mort un tel bond est
menacé par foyer il vaut mieux s'en
débarrasser tout de suite donné une
caméra carrément et puis voilà on
pourrait par exemple créer une émission
qui s'appellerait j'emmerde les autres
et qu'il permettrait aux gens qui iront
et une opinion de pouvoir empêcher les
autres de ses émissions
si vous voulez me permette loin de
servir une cause les manifestations ab
s'ils les desservent
c'est un vieux schnock évolueront
continue je ne sais pas d'où un jeu
toujours pas su ce qu'il a écrit sur
cette pancarte
enfin c'est pas grave il y avait en
ramant alors en tout cas mes enfants
vous avez amené une bouteille on va
quand même la boire et on va la boire à
la santé d'un autre kangourou d'or et de
notre étoile d'or puisque nous sommes la
seule émission où quand même on accepte
tout le monde ça se passe en liberté
vous voyez et moi je sers un verre à
tout cela parce que il faut quand même
voir tranquille tu es fan de coloriage
les fans de paul et pancartes laquelle
ya marqué je ne bois plus cadré la
pancarte de monsieur collaro veuillez
carré la poutre en bois plus non si l'on
à un sujet culinaire cette moitié de mes
chansons vont faire plaisir
reprenons la commission après c'est
après cet incident je trouve toujours
charmant je suis embêté parce que je
n'ai toujours pas lui qui avait forcé de
parker je ne peux pas en parler ça
m'embête tiens pourquoi on ne l'a pas
fait face à moi ça stéphane à la d27
semaine oui dans la qualité la semaine
il ya la fille du président de la
république fille aînée du président de
la république valériane giscard
d'estaing qui a écrit un livre de cul